this short video could potentially
change your life forever and less than
30 days from today you can make your
first money online even if you have zero
business experience there's a little
known simple but powerful method that is
now being used by people just like you
to make money from their phone using
social media in as little as 30 days
it's the same strategy I've used to
generate over five million dollars via
Tick Tock Marketing in under two years
create tons of viral Tick Tock accounts
alongside creating a massive YouTube
presence in just two months and becoming
friends with some of the most famous
people on the internet like the Tates
and snico the last podcast we talked
about the guy with the based mother and
how smart she is and how she is grown
into a woman of intellect she has kids
who are obviously 21 22 years of age she
hasn't got green hair you know she
carries herself well her son's in shape
you you could yeah are you like uh this
dude you make money right I could hear
the Ben Shapiro money conservative
Jordan Peterson in your voice yeah you
hit the nail on the head I'm a crypto
crypto guy I made a lot of money but
case you found this page by accident and
have no idea who I am my name is sunny
Fazio just a regular kid from inner city
Boston Massachusetts who found his way
to break out of the system The Tick Tock
secret I mentioned above has allowed me
to get over 10 million views on my holy
nft account in just the first week alone
and then I went on to sell out the whole
project completely at 1.2 million
dollars all of that in 30 short days
from starting The Tick Tock account it's
also allowed me to move my whole family
from the cold Boston to sunny Florida
and the only reason is because I've been
able to do something that none of your
teachers or college professors have been
able to figure out about making money
that's why they're stuck living average
lives this Tick Tock secret could
potentially transform your financial
life in just 30 days with one simple
trick it can take less than 30 minutes a
day you don't need to spend money on
hiring a team you don't need any
previous experience and you don't need
to do anything illegal or unethical in
fact it really has no risks at all and
it's all possible because of a loophole
I discovered in the social media
algorithms that allows anyone anywhere
regardless of their education income or
age to follow a simple step-by-step
directions and almost instantly be able
to make money from the internet on
demand this is the exact same secret
used by Big Time internet creators to
blow up their accounts and make tons of
money if I told you who they are you'd
instantly recognize them and until now
they've been keeping it a very close
guarded secret I discovered this by
accident two years ago when I was
messing around on this then brand new
social media platform Tick Tock and saw
firsthand how certain people went on to
make gazillions in record time Tick Tock
with the platform Tick Tock but that's
when I realized all these growth experts
and social media companies are telling
you one thing about the algorithm and
going viral yet they're doing the exact
opposite behind the scenes This Is How
They afford multi-million dollar
Mansions countless cars and private jets
as they dug in deeper I found a little
loophole that could make you go viral
and only three to five pieces of content
and it takes no more than 30 minutes a
day this loophole will not last forever
though I estimate that this rare
opportunity will only last another 12
months Max before the big social social
media Executives altered the algorithm
to stop favoring creators so much and
not only do I use this Tick Tock secret
to blow up every social media account I
have it also worked on YouTube allowing
me to grow at record speeds this has
worked so well for accounts I own that
I've racked up 100 plus million views
over a million followers sold out
multi-million dollar projects and
created countless viral accounts in just
two years I've generated over five
million dollars across my businesses as
a 19 year old so I'm not talking about
sacrificing your life to do this and it
has nothing to do with all the things
most social media experts will tell you
to do to make a big time online that's
why it's only been known to a small
handful of insiders until now and it's
the same reason that this very unique
and special loophole is probably
something that you've never heard about
and all you need is a phone and an
internet connection to do it then by
simply following a step-by-step process
for only 30 minutes a day you can
literally Force the social media
companies to blow up your account this
loophole is so powerful that social
media companies are working super hard
to prevent new creators from taking
advantage of it can you believe that
this is because they want to keep this a
closely guarded secret for as long as
they can because the less people that
know it the more money they can make
from new and struggling creators that
come in on their platforms every day so
let me explain exactly how you take
advantage LeapFrog at all and Achieve
immense growth in a short amount of time
I've seen it time and time again for
example when you make a new tick tock
account the first three to five videos
have an extremely high chance of going
viral but to supercharge this there's
certain steps that you can take to get
these videos pushed out even more there
are specific settings that will show
Tick Tock you're a real person a Creator
and not some bot account then your first
three to five videos will blow up what
we then do is properly utilize these
views to make tons of money I've done
this strategy countless times and it
works so freaking well the growth that
happens you can then leverage onto other
platforms businesses your music career
anything just like how I built a 40 000
plus strong YouTube audience in only two
months and also use it to sell out new
projects and business plans that you
take part Garden these will come flying
to you once people see the virality that
you're able to create so once you start
taking advantage of this new account
loophole you'll know exactly how to make
boatloads of money in as little as 30
days and the best part is there isn't a
single social media platform that can
stop you from doing this or stop me from
showing you how which is why I've
created an online Academy of sorts about
making money from social media without
anyone being able to stop me for now you
see not too long ago I came up with the
test group recorded some videos
revealing this loophole in great detail
and showing how anyone can take
advantage of it to change their lives
for the better and as of today thousands
of people have seen how to blow up their
social media accounts and leverage them
for big paydays on the regular faster
than they ever thought possible this has
worked for me it's worked for others and
most importantly it can work for you too
the reason why I'm sharing this
knowledge and helping others raise their
scores is twofold number one this
Insider information is going to take you
behind the scenes of how thousands of
young people just like you are beating
the system using this little known
social media loophole that I'm teaching
you and how about using the simple step
to step instructions for 30 minutes each
day you can finally say goodbye to the
average life most people have laid out
to them by Society number two once you
know how this loophole works you'll be
given the exact strategies on how to
supercharge it and go even more viral
how to produce your viral videos fast
and how to utilize those viral videos to
get incredible opportunities falling
into your lab once you follow these
instructions you'll watch your views
rack up allowing you to finally get
Cloud connections make money in line and
all the things you want and need in life
here's how to make it happen in just a
moment you'll see a button appear
underneath this video when you click
that button you'll be taken to a secure
page where you will get instant access
to this powerful social media trick and
all the ways to make money from your
phone using it once inside you'll get
taken to a short but important intro
video showing how you can get started
right away including the exact steps to
take to best optimize your account for
creating virality the steps are very
easy and I'll walk you through each one
of them answering any questions you guys
have it really is surprisingly simple I
have a tutorial walkthrough for every
single thing next you're going to be
giving my down and dirty content
production tips and tricks that will
make your videos look a grade even if
you've never shot and edited a video
before in your life experience doesn't
matter at all I've had people who've
never tried editing their Instagram
photos go on to do crazier things one
guy I taught went on to use these Tick
Tock tips for an e-commerce store and
generated a hundred thousand dollars in
a month zero ad spend another guy I
taught started in only fans marketing
agency and brought in 75 000 in a week
these are just a few of the stories
happening to others every day around the
world and when you join the academy
today it could happen to you too I am so
confident that this will work for you
I'm gonna make you an offer that you
cannot refuse normally when I teach this
one-on-one I charge at least five
thousand dollars a month but I'm doing
this neither for profit or just to teach
you one thing I'm doing this to change
lives and to additionally include
Educators to show you how to leverage
your skills in different businesses all
the way from e-commerce to real estate a
fitness program by Gabe grow and even
more also so alongside all the social
media algorithm hacks I've discovered
you'll receive daily tips and strategies
and last but not least I'll be hosting
multiple live calls a week going over
the content answering questions bringing
on famous guests live lessons and much
more plus you'll have unfiltered access
to an ever-growing community of
go-getters like yourself you can Bond
and build connections with so instead of
me charging you 300 500 or a thousand
dollars a month you can get instant
access to this Academy for only 29.99 a
month While most people sell courses for
a large one-time payment and then the
info gets outdated and then they try to
sell you on another course just going
over the problems that came up with this
Academy you'll be paying for something
monthly that will be constantly updated
I'm never releasing anything else if you
want to learn from me this is the only
option you'll ever have also that price
of 29.99 is only for the first thousand
people who sign up after these spots get
filled up the price will make its way up
to a hundred dollars a month for new
members now maybe it doesn't sound like
a big deal to you but there are high
schoolers joining who will use their
allowance for this and then within
months this will just be pocket change
for them if not sooner see I know most
people have thirty dollars let alone a
hundred to pay for this and honestly if
you didn't I'd prefer you just kept your
money because you clearly have bigger
problems if you can't set aside 30 a
month to learn how to make thousands
from your phone don't worry though it
comes with no strings attached you can
cancel at any time so just join today
use the academy to start making money
online in the next 30 days if you don't
like it simply cancel I won't ask you
any questions just send me an email or
message on Discord and you'll be removed
immediately as I said I'm not doing this
just for the money I'll be happy with
just 10 people joining and all of them
winning big so to take advantage of this
simply click on the button below and
you'll be taken to a secure registration
page once you register you will be given
a quick introductory video going over
everything and you will gain access to
the full exclusive Discord this really
is the opportunity of a lifetime to get
off the beaten path and make something
with your time on this planet if you
don't take advantage soon who knows
maybe these Executives at the social
media come companies will make it harder
for anybody new to gain success on their
platforms but I know for a fact that the
people who join now and apply themselves
to just 30 minutes a day will quickly
find the initial success they're looking
for that will open the doors for even
better opportunities in the near future
I really look forward to talking with
you personally and helping you achieve
all your financial goals and dreams
maybe you're still watching this video
instead of taking action maybe you think
you'll make it another way but you're
here on this page you're here for a
reason you invested a lot of time
watching this video you did that for a
reason too of course you could choose to
just ignore everything you've seen today
but think about this if I'm wrong and
you don't get anything out of this
you're out just a few minutes of your
time and a quick email to cancel but
what if I'm right
let's find out